selon la définition donnée des
frontières de barbelés au mur de béton
il y aurait entre 20 et 71 mur dans le
monde et peut-être un de plus d'ici
quelques mois entre la pologne et la
biélorussie des murs qui séparent les
hommes dont le plus connu de tous le mur
de berlin vous avez de la famille de
l'autre côté des parents mon fils ma
soeur
ils viennent là les berlinois de l'ouest
armée d'escabeau d'échelle dans l'espoir
d'apercevoir quelques uns des leurs de
l'autre côté de la rue de l'autre côté
du mur c'était en 1962 le mur de berlin
surnommé le mur de la honte séparer des
familles entières une séparation qui a
duré près de 30 ans jusqu'au 9 novembre
1989 ce jour là le mur tombe les
allemands se retrouve
[Applaudissements]
des scènes de liesse qui laissait croire
que plus jamais on ne verrait de mur
séparant les peuples sauf que depuis une
vingtaine d'années pour lutter contre
l'immigration les trafics de drogue ou
le terrorisme le monde sont mûrs un des
plus contestées le mur entre israël et
la palestine
le mur de la discorde le voilà un mur en
béton de huit mètres de haut construit
par israël au début des années 2000 ce
mur nous étouffe dit cet homme nous
empêche de bouger on ne peut même pas
aller à l'hôpital ou à jérusalem qui est
à cinq minutes de l'autre côté un jour
il tombera mais il est toujours debout
est depuis 20 ans la vie s'organise
autrement on se parle par dessus le mur
ici deux voisins désormais séparés règle
qu'une histoire de clés on se donne une
poignée de main furtive
les gens d'ici travail de l'autre côté
du mur
les jeunes vont au collège de l'autre
côté il n'y a pas d'hopital ici comment
ferait une femme malade elle doit sauter
voler ou quoi autre continent le mur
entre les etats-unis et le mexique
depuis le début de sa construction en
2006 par l'administration bush des
familles sont déchirés l'exemple avec
cette américaine mère de huit enfants et
son mari sont papiers renvoyé au mexique
depuis sept ans ils sont séparés
qu'est ce que vous pensez que
je le déteste il me dégoûte c'est
difficile pour nous on souffre beaucoup
partout donc les mêmes histoires de
famille d'amis séparer de vie
bouleversée par un mur
[Musique]